[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من محاور محاور
اليوم نطرحها مع الباحث في علم وتاريخ
الاديان والحضارات دكتور خزعل الماجدي
اهلا بك دكتور ماجد شكرا
على سلسله تاريخ الحضارات انطلاقا من
ميزان
لعناصر الحضاره انت من اعدها هذا الميزان
الاخلاق ما هي هذه السلسله في عجاله لو
سمحت
الحقيقه هذا مشروع من المشاريع الاساسيه
في شغلي وهو ان اكتب تاريخ الحضارات
البشريه باكملها
وهذا التاريخ
يعني يمتد من تقريبا بدايه العصور
التاريخيه
والى يومنا هذا فبدات بالمشروع والان
وصلنا الى الكتاب التاسع
24 25 ثم يضاف لها مجموعه من الكتب
النظريه عن الحضارات ميزان الحضاره التي
تراها امامك الان نعم موجود الحقيقه هذا
انا وضعته
من خلال يعني همم
شعوري بانه كثير من المؤلفين في هذا
المجال اهملوا الكثير من جوانب الحضاره
فاسميتها بعناصر الحضاره المكونه من سبع
عناصر همم ماديه وسبعه ناصر مثاليه او
لنقل ثقافيه او حتى معنويه
الحقيقه ميزه الجدول او الميزان هذا انها
تتقابل وتتكامل مع بعضها يعني واحده في
مقابل الاخرى بالضبط يعني ليست التسلسل
ليس اعتبارها يعني هو موزع بشكل وهذه
العناصر الماديه الجغرافيه سياسيه
العسكريه الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه الطاقه
العلميه في مقابلها العناصر الثقافيه
التاريخيه والقانونيه والمدنيه
والادب والفكر والنفسيه والدينيه
والفنيه هذه تضبطها عنصر مهم جدا والعنصر
الخامس عشر في هذا الميزان وهي الاخلاق
فان عندما ترتقي الحضاره تجد انها تتماسك
في اخلاقها لكن عندما تنهار يبدا ال- ال-
الفساد يدبه يعني في الاخلاق وبذلك تنهار
الحضاره فوجدت ان هذا الموضوع ينطبق على
الكثير من الحضارات العالم القديم
وبدات بالحقيقه بالمشروع عبر تصنيف شخصي
انا وضعته
لتصنيف الحضارات البشريه على اساس المراحل
التاريخيه يعني هناك حضاره العصور القديمه
او تاريخ القديم وهناك حضارات التاريخ
الوسيط وهناك حضاره التاريخ الحديث او
الحضاره الحديثه فاصبح عندنا مجموعه هذه
الحضارات يقرب من 26 الحضاره
الان وصلت الى ما زلت في القديم بصراحه
ووصلت اخر كتاب هو الحضاره اليمنيه طبعا
وعلى الحضاره اليمنيه ستكون المحور
الاساسي في هذه الحلقه
[موسيقى]
ان تخصص
مؤلف بجزئين ضخمين للحضاره اليمنيه وتعتبر
ان هذه الحضاره متفرده في اقليمها في
الاقليم الجغرافي بمعنى ضمن منطقه صحراويه
الحضاره اليمنيه عانت من اهمال شديد
بما يسمى ماقبل الاسلام
ولها كل عناصر الحضاره الخمسه عشر بشكل
كتابات المسند
والزبور فهي حضاره كبيره الحقيقه لكن
للاسف الشديد ضاعت في تسلسل الحضارات عبر
مؤلفين الحضاره خصوصا الغربيين انا اعدت
الاعتبار لهذه الحراره وتحدثت عنها بادق
التفاصيل يعني عملت 15 فصل لكل واحد مظهر
القانوني
هناك سؤال دائما انطلقت
اجراءات العربيه من جزيره العرب او من
اليمن انت لا توافق على هذا الامر
قديمه واصبحت الان غير يعني غير موفقه
ابدا في تفسير ما يحصل خصوصا ان الاثار لا
تدعمها يعني لا يوجد اثار على وجود شعوب
كما يقال انه خرجت من من جزيره العرب او
حتى من اليمن في الزمن الاسبق لتذهب الى
مناطق المشرق الاعلى او المشرق القديم في
مناطق العلويه ال- الحقيقه هي العكس ان
المنجزات همم الزراعيه والمنجزات همم في
العصر الحجري النحاسي هي التي كثرت الناس
واصبحت هناك مدن واصبحت هناك قرى وشعرها
في مناطق شمال وادي الرافدين وسوريا وهذه
المنطقه يعني مشرق القديم هي منبع
الحضارات القديمه منبع الشعوب الساميه ما
يسمى وهي التي لا اقول هاجرت ان من انتشرت
في المناطق المشرق بشكل خاص
وهذا ايضا يعزز فكره ان هناك مؤثرات من
هذا المشرق على نمو الحضاره اليمنيه نعم
الشعب اليمني بكل فصائله كان موجوده وهو
صاحب ما يسمى بعصور ما قبل التاريخ هم
المزارعين وهم بناه المدن الاوائل ولكن
تحفزت هذه الحضاره بشكل اكبر في العصر
الحديدي قرابه القرن الثامن قبل الميلاد
اليمنيون بالدرجه الاساس هو سبائيون الذين
بدرجه الاساس لكن طبعا هناك مالك اخرى غير
المملكه السبائيه نمت بجوارها مثل همم
النعيليين وهمم القتبانيين لكن وجود
الاتحاد السبع هو الذي وحد كل هذه وهم لم
يكونوا عرب لكن همم الاقرب
هم ساميون لكن اقرب الناس قالوا له هم
العرب بحكم التجاور الحقيقي
فانا اميز العرب واليمنيين القدماء طبعا
باعتبار ان هناك خصوصيه كامله في منطقه
اليمن يعني همم تؤيدها الاثار وتؤيدها
اللغه وخط المسند والى اخره تتميز الحقيقه
عن شيء اسمه العرب والنقوش العربيه التي
ظهرت متاخره
لكن طبعا عندما جاء الاسلام جمع العرب مع
اليمن واصبح اليمن عربي وهو عربي الى
يومنا هذا طبعا اما الدقه التاريخيه
تستوجب مني ان اميز بين شعوب سكنت اليمن
وانتجت هذه الحراره وبين ما كان يحيطها من
العرب في العلاقه الجنسيه
بشكل خاص يعني تقول في مكان تذكر الحال ان
همم الدوله همم الحميريه مثلا كانت همم
يهوديه تقريبا
في زمن يوسف اثار اللي هو احد ملوك اليمن
الدين اليهودي بشكل خاطئ لانه لا يجوز ان
يصبح يعني يصبح يهوديا دون امني يهوديه هو
يتبنى مثل ما حصل فيه في دوله الخزر بعد
التاسعه والعاشر هو تبني الدين اليهود
اعجب به وتبناه ااا
تحول الشعب اليمني او اغلب الشعب اليمني
تقريبا في القرن الرابع
الميلادي همم في هذا الفتره طبعا كانت
اليمن تعاني من اضطرابات كثيره جدا لان
عادت فكره القبيله وتغلبت على فكره
المدينه يعني هي الحقيقه هذه المشكله
اليمنيه المعروفه جدا ان ال- ال- الحسي
القبلي عالي جدا بحيث كان ساهم بهذا الاسم
القبلي او التكوين القبلي في الوقت اللي
ساهم في نشوها عندما وضع في اطار مدنين
وفي اتحاد ممالك وكذا لكنه للاسف الشديد
عاده فاصبح سببا لتفككه تحولت
القبائل الى اليهوديه ثم تحولت الى
المسيحيه عند بتاثير من الاحباش والدوله
البيزنطيه ومن ثم الى الاسلام وهذا كله
قبل الاسلام وبذلك اليمن اصبحت خاضعه
لمكانين متصارعين خارجهم وهي الدوله
الساسانيه والدوله البيزنطيه فتخيل ان هذه
الحضاره العظيمه اصبحت بها التجاذبات
خارجيه هذا ساهم الحقيقه في تشريع سقوطها
مع الاسئله
طبعا هذه عوامل اخرى بالتاكيد طبعا حصلت
في مع الاسف ايضا حصلت في نفس الفتره بسبب
ايضا عدم الاعتناء بالمنجزات
العلميه والحضاريه التي كانت موجوده يعني
اليمنيين الذين انشاوا سد مارب في فتره
مبكر جدا
وساهموا في يعني هذا الشد ساهم في جمع
اليمنيين في يعني حضاره ممتازه ارمله هذا
السيد فيما بعد الى انهار في فتره متاخره
متزامنه مع هذه تداخلات الاجنبيه واصبح
عاملا لنقل الماديه لانهيار هذه الحراره
لكن الانهيار الحقيقي هو في طريقه التفكير
وفي تبني الديان خارج المكان يعني من خارج
المكان دخلت الى المكان واصبحت محطه تنافس
بين اليمنيين واحتراب داخلي بسبب العقيده
الدينيه العقيده الدينيه الوافده
اكيد ما الدين الذي كان في في الحضاره
اليمنيه
مكون من ثالوت وكانت في نزعه توحيديه
عاليه عبر الالهيه هذه
همم رحمن يعني كانت موجوده الحقيقه
ممتازه للتوحيد وحتى فعلا اثناء الاختزام
هذا ظهرت محاوله
لابتكار او وضع توحيد يمني خاص وهي لكن
الوقت كانت بحيث
ظهر مباشره بعد الاسلام فالاسلام جمع شتات
اليمن الذي كان على وشك التمزق وضمه له
واصبحت جزء من
الحضاره الاسلاميه العماره
الحقيقه العماره اليمنيه معروف جدا
وشواهدها الى اليوم نشوفها ماما مميزه
يعني
بالاضافه لهذه النقوش العظيمه الجميله جدا
على واجهاتها
والحدود التي تؤطر الشبابيك والابواب
والمدرجات
ما يسمى بالابراج المعماريه يعني اللي هي
عماره من طوابق عديده جدا حتى وصفها بعضهم
بانها ناطحات سحاب القديمه يعني تصل
احيانا الى 10 واكثر من التوابق فهذه ميزه
عظيمه يعني هذا احنا دائما اؤكد على
الحضاره في الجانب العمران
انجزوا جانب عمران عظيم جدا سواء في ال ال
ال ال العماره اليمنيه او في بناء السدود
وهنا قصور وهناك معابد لا نظير لها يعني
اكبر معبد في جزيره العرب بكاملها هو معبد
اوام اللي هو يعني
للاله المقاه يعني كان في حتى تراجي حج
وتراج الاحرام كل شيء كان في يعني كان على
اصوله الحقيقه لكن
ماذا تقول لشيء حصل في تقريبا يعني القرون
المتاخره وبدات تضعف هذه الحضاره شيئا
فشيئا اليوم
باقيه في ضمير والوجدان اليمني الى يومنا
هذا وحتى في ضمير بمعنى انه يحافظ لانتاج
شخصيه حضاريه مميزه واتمنى فعلا ان هذه
الحضاره تبقى حاضره في اذان اليمنيين
لكرينجز ما عليهم في العصر الحديث بشرط ان
يخففوا من موضوع الانتماء القبلي وان
يلجاوا الى العلم الحديث والى الطراز
الحديث في في في الحضاره ليبنوا بلدا مهما
في منطقته
همم
الاستعراض الحضاره اليمنيه بهذه الطريقه
الضخمه في الكتاب هو يعزز من ثقه اليمني
بحضارته وبنفسه وبما انجز قبل ما يقرب من
2500 سنه او حتى اكثر بكثير
فالحقيقه اليمن يعني مفخره من فاخر من
منطقه الشرق الادنى يعني تخيل عندما بدات
تغرب او تميل الى الغروب حضارات اللي
موجوده في بلاد وادي الرافدين وبلاد الشام
وحتى مصر الحضاره
لهذا المكان طيب لماذا لا توافق على مساله
ان التوراه يمكن ان تكون منطبقه او تنطبقه
على الجغرافيا اليمن كما طرحهم كمان
في في فلسطين
لها تاريخ الخاص بعيد عن المرويات
التوراتيه التي لاومن بها مطلقا انا همم
امين همم الاثار التي الاثار همم
قليله جدا في ما يخص نشات اليهوديه في ذلك
المكان ولكن نلمس بعضها في في
قريب من القرون الميلاديه من مخطوطات
البحر الميت الى الدوله المكانيه الى
غيرها اما ان ان نختصر كل هذا بمجموعه
مقارنات في الجغرافيا وان هذا المكان يشبه
ذلك وبالتالي نضع كل كل اليهوديه في اليمن
فهذا شيء خاطئ بالكامل يعني بالنسبه لك
الاثار هي
دليل الملموس الوحيد بالنسبه لقراءه
الحضارات القديمه
في كل العالم وليس في منطقتنا فقط في كل
العالم
يعني الخلاصه اليوم بعد قراءه او تاليف كل
الاحوال هذا المؤلف ضخم عن الحضاره
يمنيه الحقيقه لو تاملنا في المنجزات
الحضاريه لليمن لوجدناها فيها خصوصيه
عاليه جدا على سبيل المثال يضرب لك امثله
بسيطه جدا يعني الملك اليمني
لم يكن كما في ابن ابن الاله او اله في
الحضارات المشرقيه ولم يكن نائبا عن الاله
ليس هكذا كان مقيدا بما يسمى بالمسود اللي
هو يعني المجلس الاداري الشامل للمملكه
فترضى عنه مجالس او المسودات المدن
ومشودات اخرى
وتعطيه الحريه يعني هو مقيد ليس شخص حر
ولا يتصرف كما يريد هذا هذا حقيقه موجود
في مناطق يعني موجود بها الطريقه على
الاقل يمكن في نظاره بسيطه جدا ظهرت مبكره
في وادي الرافدين لكنها لم تستمر لكن وجود
المجهود الذي يلزم او يمسك حركه الملك كان
انجاز سياسي مهم جدا في ذلك الزمن
كما قلت لك ال ال ال السدود وغيرها وايضا
هناك ابتكار عظيم جدا في اليمن وهو ما
يسمى بمدرجات الزراعيه يعني تعرفات
اليمنيه كثيره جدا فقسم الجبل او شطب على
شكل مدرجات وكانوا يستثمرون المطر في
اسقاء هذه الارض لم تكن هناك انهار في
اليمن القديم يعني فاستخدم لا يستطيعون
المطر اللي هو ايضا لم يكن ثابتا في مراسل
بالضروره بالضبط
زراعيه بشكل كامل
على طول تاريخيه يعني لم ااه لن يستورد
هذه الاشياء ثم التي جرت اليمن كانت واحده
من التجارات المميزه جدا في التاريخ
لتجاره البخور ولادن وهمم المواد الاخرى
الصمغيه التي كانت تستعمل في المعابد كانت
تجاره عظيمه جدا على ضوئيها سميت باليمن
السعيده سميت لانها ثروه هائله يعني كانت
قطع صغيره من هذه المواد تباع تباع باسماء
على امل ان يعود اليمن سعيدا شكرا
لك يا دكتور خزعل الماجدي على المشاركه في
محاوله
في حلقه جديده من محور
[موسيقى]